[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact in 2018 China celebrated
the opening of the Hong Kong zhuhai
Macao bridge the bridge and tunnel
linking Hong Kong to mainland China via
Macau it opened in 2018 it now claims
the title as the world's longest sea
bridge the vast structure stretches more
than 34 miles through the Pearl River
River Delta is going to be servicing
eleven cities around the bay that are
home to a combined 68 million people
because it's such a busy shipping area a
section of the colossal bridge plunges
under water turning into a four mile
long tunnel via two man-made islands the
structure is an unparalleled engineering
feat 20 times the length of the Golden
Gate Bridge builders used about 1
million cubic yards of cement to help
withstand earthquakes and the seasonal
typhoons that often tear through the
region the mammoth project began in 2009
yet because of delays and safety
concerns 19 men died during the
construction it took nearly 10 years to
complete at an estimated 20 billion
dollars mankind has often paid dearly to
build bridges between cities but God
paid even more to build a bridge between
heaven and earth stay with his friends
were going to learn more on this edition
of Bible answers lie
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 and if you've
never joined us on Facebook you often do
so it's at the doug batchelor facebook
page and also at the amazing facts
facebook page so you can just join us
here and see what's happening in the
studio and participate in the program
well let's start the program with prayer
dear father once again we thank you that
we have this opportunity to study the
Bible and Lord we ask for your guidance
we pray for the Holy Spirit to be with
us here in Sacramento but also around
the world for those who are listening
and lead us loading to a clearer and
fuller understanding of your word and
your will for we ask this in Jesus name
Amen amen
pastor thank you open the program by
talking about a very very long bridge
actually the longest sea bridge in the
world now I know you have and I have
we've driven on some rather long bridges
in different places around the world but
to have a bridge that long not only is
it above water but then it plunges into
a tunnel that actually goes under the
water it's quite an incredible feat
that's amazing you know it's easy to see
that the Chinese built a wall 1,500
miles long you know what 1500 years ago
and they like building colossal projects
like the Three Gorges Dam actually the
longest bridge in the world is also in
China it's a hundred and two
along but it's over freshwater and it's
you know kind of a state it's got pylons
and it's pretty even reminds me of the
bridge between the Florida Keys and Key
West
yeah just to build this sea bridge where
you've got the typhoons coming and to
connect the mainland like that and you
just think about it sixty-eight million
people live around that Bay that's it's
hard to comprehend when you can send
like San Francisco Bay you know is maybe
eight million people this is 68 million
people so it's pretty incredible but you
think about the bridges and it makes me
think about a one of the most incredible
bridges is the one that bridged heaven
and earth and that bridge was built out
of a Cross God so loved the world he
sent his son to connect us and and give
us that hope that opportunity to pass
from this life into heaven and into
eternity and we have a free offer
tonight friends if you not made that
decision to accept that gift of
everlasting life in the new heart that
Jesus offers we'd like you to take
advantage of our offer tonight the book
again is called the high cost of the
Cross and we want to send this to anyone
who'd call and ask the number is 883
five six seven four seven and tonight
you want to be sure to call that
resource number 800 eight three five six
seven four seven ask for the book it's
our free offer it's called the high cost
of the Cross and we'll send this to
anyone who calls and asks we're gonna go
to our first caller this evening we have
Dennis who is listening in Arizona
Dennis welcome to the program thank you
good evening evening my question is what
about the people who have never heard
about
oops I think we lost Dennis there Dennis
if you're listening it looks like we
might have had a little bit of a
computer glitch and looked like the cold
dropped off there for a second
I think the screener had actually typed
out the call and what Dennis was asking
I trust he's still listening what about
all the people in the world who had not
heard about Jesus does that mean they're
all automatically lost that's a very
good question you got to answer it
carefully because first of all it tells
us Peter tells us in the book of Acts I
think it's chapter 4 that there is no
other name given among men whereby we
must be saved so let's make it clear
right at the beginning if anybody's
saved they're gonna be in heaven because
of Jesus but can a Christian then say
all those millions of people that may
have lived in you know Australia or
Africa or North America that or even the
masses in China how are we talking about
yeah that never heard about Jesus for
thousands of years that all of them are
lost I think you've got to be very
careful not to say that because you know
Jesus does say the hour is coming in
which all that are in the graves will
hear his voice and come forth they that
have done good the resurrection of life
and they that have done evil the
resurrection of damnation now it's not
that a person is saved by doing good
we're only saved by the grace of God but
there are people who through their life
they have lived up to the light they had
they've walked in the voice of the Holy
Spirit we know that angels have visited
people who maybe never heard the gospel
before you know the Lord has ways of
sharing the gospel and sharing himself
with you now let me give you some other
scripture when when Jesus began his
ministry and he preached in Nazareth he
started the sermon by saying there were
many lepers in the land in the days of
Elijah or Elijah but none of them was
cleansed except Naaman the Syrian
meaning here he's a non Jew yet God
works a miracle for him and then he says
there were many widows in the land in
the days of Elijah but Elijah wasn't
sent to any of the Israeli widows he was
sent to Phoenician Widow
and he worked a miracle of a
resurrection for her just like Elijah
worked a miracle of healing from leprosy
for name and Jesus is saying be careful
not to say you know because we're Jews
or because we're Christians but God
never works with our heels or saves or
answers prayers of people who maybe
don't know all about how the Lord you've
got that woman at the well in Samaria
she's a Samaritan which you know the
Jews just scorned and yet Jesus revealed
to her he was the Messiah and then you
have the story of the Good Samaritan
that Christ said this man is the one
that God used to show mercy I think
there are people that you know of course
truth sets people free and the people
are living in darkness and it's so
urgent that missionaries go and share
Jesus and salvation but I think we need
to stop short of saying well if people
haven't heard if they're living in one
of these what we call a dark country
that all of them are lost for through
history the anomaly monitor verse find
in John chapter one verse nine talking
of Jesus it says he's the light which
gives light to every man that cometh
into the world so it seems the Holy
Spirit is speaking to the hearts of all
man how they respond to that I think is
very important some people are living up
to all the life that they might have if
you were listening to the program a few
moments ago or at least were on the
phone
waiting to ask your question and then
you got dropped off we would encourage
you to call back we had a little
software glitch but it looks like
everything is up and running well we're
in California they just cut the power
right now and then you were without
power for I was several days actually
yeah more than once if you have a Bible
question again the number to call is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven and that'll get your call
into the program and we'll try and get
your question on tonight's program you
know I did see one of the callers that
had called in they typed out a brief
question they had a question on the book
of Ezra chapter 2 verse 13 it's an
interesting verse
and it says the people of a tonight come
666 now I'm just speculating the person
calling in with a question is thinking
well that's interesting
666 you don't see that number too often
in the Bible we know that number appears
in Revelation as an identifying number
for the Antichrist beast power and maybe
they're asking hmm here's another
example of 666 what does that mean well
I could only speculate first of all I
think we've got to be careful not to
read too much in it because if you give
enough random numbers you're gonna come
up with 666 you look that number is
surrounded by a lot of other numbers and
it's numbering people that had come back
with Ezra to Jerusalem so it says the
family of Adonai command the word Adonai
come it's similar to the Hebrew name for
God I don't I is their 666 so you know
if you're at a football stadium and all
the seats are number one of those seats
is gonna be 666 it doesn't mean you've
got the mark of the beast of you sit in
that seat you know the name a tonight
come which was sort of the Lido this
group that came the name literally means
my Lord is risen as is looking at the
translation in Strong's that is an
interesting name that you find in the
Old Testament my Lord is risen yeah that
is something sort of an allusion to
Christ being risen from the dead that's
you know what the disciples said all
right we're ready for our next caller we
have Becky listening in Michigan Becky
welcome to the program hello pastor doc
are you good Vicki thank you for calling
focal point what is persecution what do
you do about it
well Jesus says in the Beatitudes pray
for those who despitefully use you and
persecute you that you might be the
children of your father in heaven who
sends the sunshine and the rain on the
just and the unjust now that's easier
said than done but you know it's hard to
be angry at people when you're praying
for them if you're a believer and you're
being persecuted for righteousness sake
Jesus tells us in the Beatitudes rejoice
because they persecuted the prophets
before you if you keep in mind that you
know lost people hopefully it's it's not
safe people that are persecuting you but
if people are lost they're gonna act
lost Christians aren't just to love the
saved Jesus said you got to love the
lost even if they're mean and he even
said you need to love your enemy and
that's like yeah again I'm saying that's
easier said than done
you know I like everyone else I've had
people that have said and done some
pretty unkind things and and the Lord
convicts me instead of conjuring
terrible scenarios that might happen to
them I need to pray for them in their
salvation and you can only do that with
the grace of God you know we do have a
book that deals with the subject and I
think you'll find this encouraging Becky
if you'd call and ask it's called the
brook dried up the brook dried up and
then there's a sub question that says
why do Christians suffer and it actually
deals with your very question of what
happens when one faces trials and
difficulties or is being persecuted by
someone else and of course it builds on
the story of Elijah who faced
persecution will be happy to send that
to you all you'll have to do Becky is
just call our resource line and that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
again asked for the book when the brook
dried up and we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks anyone who
needs encouragement if you're going
through some trials that is a great book
if you have a Bible question a phone
line here to the studio is 800 four six
three seven two nine seven I'm gonna say
it again
so if you got a pencil a pen you're
ready to write it down 800 four six 372
97 with your Bible question if you don't
get through right away don't give up
keep calling and you'll get onto the
program this evening
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time call us at
[Music]
1-800-455-1052
Dani in southwest Oklahoma Dan welcome
to the program yes hi thanks for calling
you're on the air
well the fella that called in wanting to
know what would happen to the people
that hadn't heard the gospel yes well if
you look in Revelation 14 6 it says and
I saw another angel fly in the midst of
heaven having the everlasting gospel to
preach unto them that dwell on the earth
and to every nation and kindred and
tongue and people so everyone will hear
the gospel so they will have no excuse
where Jesus says in Matthew 24 that the
gospel of the kingdom will be preached
in all the world for a witness to all
nations yeah now of course I think the
person was asking what about before the
gospel is preached you know let's
suppose you go back 200 years and you
say you know what about people that were
living in the Brazilian jungle that
maybe never heard about Jesus are they
all automatically lost and so I was
saying that it's very important most
people without God are lost but it was
yeah we've got to stop short of saying
that you know God is not able to save
them through some other means besides a
human preacher God can speak to people
through angels and through his spirit
and we got to be careful not to judge
but I appreciate your your question your
comment Dennis at revelation 14:6 is a
great passage okay we've got one
listening in Washington one welcome to
the program
yes sir and your question when Jesus was
a baby
there was a decree footed by the king he
motor all the babies yes
welcome John but wasn't persecuted or
the Bible doesn't say anything about him
well because John the Baptist wasn't
necessarily born in Bethlehem
King Herod when he interviewed the wise
men they said you know we've been guided
by the star to Jerusalem and then Herod
interviews the the pre census where is
the Messiah supposed to come from and
they quoted the prophecy out of
Bethlehem so he didn't kill all the
babies throughout Jerusalem or Judea he
just killed the babies two years old and
under male babies around Bethlehem so
John the Baptist I don't think we read
any where he was born or lived in
Bethlehem thank you so much
alright good question thank you so much
you know one of the interesting things
about that is that's the third time that
the devil tried to wipe out Jesus by
murdering baby boys in Egypt he thought
a savior was coming and so they were
trying to exterminate all of the Hebrew
children back when King Juan during the
time of a ham yeah the the daughter of
Ahab atholea killed all of the
descendants of David she tried she
missed one even the babies because they
you know the devil heard the Messiah was
going to come through the line of David
but they missed joash going into
Bethlehem and killing the baby boys it's
like the third time in history the devil
tried to prevent the savior from coming
by annihilating the baby boys and then
by the way then you go to Revelation and
a dragon's trying to devour a woman
bringing forth a baby mm-hmm
so next whole of that we have is looks
like we've got the Abraham listening
from San Antonio Texas
Abraham welcome to the program Abraham
you're on the air Abraham can you hear
us
sometimes they got the mute on all right
we might go back to here in just a
second let's see we got Dan in South
Carolina Dan welcome to the program you
on the air
all right good evening evening I've had
a question for a long time
when did the original requirement come
from that there had to be blood
sacrifice for sin in the Old Testament I
know that through you know Moses and the
requirements were for that but even
before then when when did that
requirement the specific command is is
not seen but you see it by
circumstantial evidence that it must
have been given to Adam
I think revelation talks about the lamb
slain from the foundation of the world
when Adam and Eve sinned they tried to
cover their their nakedness with fig
leaves and God said that won't work and
it says God gave them skins now in order
to get skin an animal had to die so we
believe that the Lord established a
sacrificial system way back there in the
Garden of Eden and another reason is the
children of Adam and Eve like Abel he
brought a lamb sacrifice and God
accepted his sacrifice so Adam must have
been instructed and then of course
Abraham offered sacrificing and all the
patriarchs it talks about them and of
course you find that in Genesis chapter
4 and it talks about verse 4 Word says
Abel brought the firstborn of his flocks
and offered that as a sacrifice and then
there's also a reference that some had
made and it makes sense after Adam and
Eve sinned first of all they tried to
hide their nakedness with fig leaves but
then the Lord made coats of skin to
cover them so some have suggested maybe
at that point we had the first animal
sacrifice yeah
and then even certainly when you get to
the story of Noah Noah was told to take
the clean animals and that would mean
not only clean for food but clean for
sacrifice by sevens and the first thing
Noah does after the ark safely lands is
he offers a sacrifice to the Lord you
know when you see it in the Garden of
Eden you don't actually have a record of
where God commands it but you can see
the the evidence of it there and then
of course Abel and onward hope that
helps Dan appreciate your question
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
855-578-6767 ebuddy based on their
bloodline you know you see great
patriarchs in the Bible Abraham Adam and
Eve you know he had good son or bad son
David had some good kids and some bad
kids so no one was saved by bloodline
the Bible says the father's not safe for
the son or the son for the father
everyone has to have a personal
relationship with the Lord but he did
commit to the Jewish nation the Oracles
of God and that's in Romans somewhere I
can't remember we also have a reference
in Romans chapter 11 verse 17 I think
that's the reference here pass it
everywhere it says and if some of the
branches were broken off and you being a
wild
olivetree were grafted in among them and
with them became partakers of the root
and the fatness of the olive tree now of
course Paul is writing head to the
Gentiles and says that they are the ones
who are grafted in and then he goes on
to explain how some of the branches were
cut off
meaning the Jews who rejected the
Messiah who rejected Christ so you have
this grafting in if you have believed
then you Abraham's seed heirs according
to the promise
yep all right well by the way I just
thought pastor like you've got a sermon
series I think it's available on YouTube
where you talk about spiritual Israel
mm-hmm well I did a series with Steve
Walberg and Jeff is our minsky talking
about is it is it kosher for a Jew to be
a Christian yes or was Jesus kosher for
the Jews they can see that online we
carried it amazing facts we also have
that sermon book called spiritual Israel
that they can get by calling in or find
it online if you'd like to receive the
book the number to call is eight hundred
eight thirty five six seven four seven
that is the resource phone line and
again you can ask to the book called
spiritual Israel and we'll be happy to
send it out to anyone who calls and asks
have you ever wondered how can I share
Jesus with my Jewish friends amazing
facts has recently produced a
fascinating three-part DVD series called
is Jesus kosher for Jews in these new
programs three Jews Steve Wahlberg Jeff
sir Minsky and myself relate our
personal encounter with a Christian
faith so pick up a copy today for
yourself and share one with your Jewish
friends call 800 five three eight seven
275 or visit us at 8 F bookstore com to
get yours and let's see we have Bill
listening from Sacramento bill we have
about a one minute before the break
billing a question hello yes you're on
the air okay I was just concerned I was
wondering if you could consider his dad
the justified suit that well I don't
know it technically you could argue it
was a suicide but Samson knew they
brought him into the temple of Dagon
they were probably going to kill him
that day they were making sport of him
he basically laid his life down you know
if you see a soldier in a battle that is
laying his life down to save other
soldiers well if he jumps on a hand
grenade to save his friends is it a
suicide you could say it is but it's
also really a sacrifice Samson was
giving himself to save God's people from
their enemies when he pushed down the
building he knew the Philistines had
been oppressing his people he basically
gave His life to give one final stroke
to the enemy I feel like he was just a
chosen vessel of God yeah well you know
of course he made Samson made a lot of
problems misusing the gifts that God had
given him but at the end he of course
repented and he was filled with the Holy
Spirit and then in Hebrews chapter 11
Samson is mentioned as listed among the
saved so bill we think Samson's going to
be in the kingdom he repented of a sin
he wept if friends were taking a brief
break we do have lines open call second
half is sometimes the best 804 6 3 7 2
97 be right back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers seek his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
538 seventy two seventy five
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 the Christian
life
I am Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
and next caller is calling from Folsom
Sacramento actually from Folsom near
Sacramento Cole are you on the air
calling from Folsom Sacramento
can you hear us you're on the air hello
yeah welcome oh hi I'm I wanted to ask
real quick because I just found your
station
I've never called before what do you do
or can you give me scripture when your
husband and son aren't walking with like
walking the way they're supposed to be
walking maybe you can give me some
scripture I you know as far as you know
they are have made a vow to you know
God but they you know they've they've
accepted him as their Savior but how I
think your screen or put it best like
she she did it for me so like can you
read that you know figure out what I'm
trying so that you know they may not
they don't read their Bible to go to
church but they they say they're
Christians and so how can you as wife
and mother try to encourage them yeah
you know one verse comes to mind is well
let me just tell you there's three
things that you can do for those you
love you want to reach and there's only
three things but they're three powerful
things one is if they're open share
information that could be in the form of
a Bible study a Christian book a website
you know a DVD or something that has
spiritual information that they'll
listen to or look at that will encourage
them so if they're open say you need to
watch this and people are often moved by
testimonies or Bible studies after you
do that whether they'll accept that or
not you do your best then the other
thing is you pray and prayer is of
course very powerful in a lot of
examples of intercessory prayer in the
Bible you need to do that persistently I
guess that's the fourth thing is do all
these things persistently and the third
thing would be be an example how you
witness with your life now here's a
verse for you in 1st Peter chapter 3
wives likewise be submissive to your own
husbands that if any does not obey the
word they can without a word be one by
the conduct of the wives when they
observe your chaste conduct accompanied
by fear you know and that is you know
really addressing a husband wife
relationship but it's basically saying
through your example is another powerful
witness there may be pastor ross has
some other ideas but you know i'm always
encouraged when we have these kind of
questions i think of a few examples that
i know of where a wife prayed fervently
for a husband for many years and it
seemed like it he just wasn't responding
but just by example of being a true
godly woman
near the end of his life he actually
gave his life fully to the Lord he was
actually baptized and I remember at his
baptism he gave the testimony and he
said the reason I'm getting baptized
today is because the faithful examples
given by my wife and of course she was
just thrilled that he had fine it
finally made the decision but just her
faithfulness even though sometimes it
was difficult he'd eventually paid off
so you never know that's right
gotta be patient oh boy am I 20 years
patient and I'm doing all three of those
things you all set and I am making sure
that I am representing the integrity the
character and all of those things that
go along with being that example like
you had mentioned because I'm doing it
out of the Lord what he says in that
scripture what you said and also as an
example to them well my husband so what
I expect from him I'm also doing like
I'm not saying well you should do this
and do this and do this but I'm not
doing and I'm a wife but never nagging I
never say anything well that's a good
example
Olivia faith I just kind of let him do
what he wants but I mean you know what
I'm in reason right I know what you're
saying yeah don't be afraid every now
and then you've got a couple of extremes
you got one extreme of the wife that
nags and that actually can drive a man
or you know wife your nag by her husband
you can drive them away then you can be
so tolerant that they're almost
surprised by your not having any
expectations and so you know every now
and then if the door opens you might
want to say you know I just want you to
know as you know it would mean so much
to me if you'd go to church with me or
we've got this special you know program
happening or or I read this and you know
just say you this really inspired me you
might like it so you know just every now
and then a gentle reminder what they
probably already know is I think very
helpful
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts when Susan's and
Michael's whirlwind relationship led to
a wedding they had no idea how hard
married life could be before they knew
it they were on the stormy path towards
divorce but that's when God led them to
an amazing fax broadcast and there they
saw the biblical view of marriage as
presented in knowing Jesus and today
Susan and Michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
Michael and Susan would you prayerfully
consider sending a gift today to help
others know Christ and the wonderful
truth that you've learned and it's easy
to make a donation give us a call at 877
five zero six one seven five one or just
visit give dot amazing facts dot o-r-g
or send your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight
thank you for tuning in to Bible answers
live and don't forget to share with
others the amazing Bible facts you have
learned here today
we have Laura listening in Maryland
Laura welcome to the program
hi hi hi thanks for calling no problem I
have a question so um for infant to
toddler ages you know the young children
what does the Bible say about their say
as far as salvation I know there are
people who say that but you know it's
based off of salvation or the lives of
the parents but I just wanted to know
what could the Bible say about their
salvation if they died you know
unfortunately at an early age maybe
three years old two years or so in
yeah you know that is a great question
it's also in a way a tough question I
think it's in pastor Ross's at first
Corinthians 7 where it says that the
children are sanctified by the believing
parent and you might look there for me
and that's one verse now the Bible is
pretty clear that children before the
age of accountability now and the Bible
doesn't say well when they reach 12
because the age of accountability is
determined by their understanding and
that may vary from child a child I think
we all know there's you know some people
because it may be a mental challenge
they act like children in their 30s they
just never grow up and you know God
probably treats them if they've got some
kind of handicap treats and like
children so if a child dies before the
age of accountability they're not
punished for the sins they may commit
because they're doing it just by nature
they may not know the consequences Bible
says sin is knowing to do good and not
doing it yeah first Corinthians chapter
7 verse 14 so that's the reference there
and then one other I don't want to dare
pass today you know we have that passage
in Jeremiah Jeremiah chapter 31 verse 16
that actually was quoted with reference
to the destruction of the little baby
boys at the time of Christ's birth and
it talks about it's actually cold in the
Old Testament prophecy in Jeremiah 31 16
that says the children shall a return
from the land of the enemy so you have a
reference there to the resurrection for
all of those little babies that were
were killed so that does also give us
the understanding that before the age of
accountability based upon the parents
there is hope at the resurrection for
them
now there is one okay go ahead I'm sorry
no no I was just clarifying so it so it
has to do with the age of if they don't
reach the age of accountability and also
the parents yes if i understood right
yes yeah and there is one verse someone
might want to know then does that mean
that I mean child mortality is the
highest of any group
does that mean every child who dies
before the age of accountability around
the world throughout history
automatically is in heaven you know a
lot of scholars stopped short of that
they definitely won't be punished but
it's like in the book of Job I think
it's in chapter 3 he talks about he's
cursing the day of his birth he said
might I be like a child a stillborn
infant that had not been you know there
may be some that will be as though they
had not been we definitely know they're
not being punished but theoretically if
every child of every human that dies
prior to the age of accountability is
automatically in heaven it would it
would be a nursery so we don't know we
all we know is that bottle is clear that
you know they're not going to be
punished before they know anyway hope
that helps a little bit more that's a
great question a tough question - next
Cola that we have is calling from New
Jersey we have Lenny Lenny welcome to
the program
hi hi how are you I'm okay and your
question yeah
my question is this under Sabbath School
lesson and we saw that manomaya when he
was when he went back to Jerusalem to
rebuild a wall and they were being
opposed by the people the surrounding
nation they were he asked to be less to
the carrier squad they were working with
us well in Holland they were working
with the other hand now I wanted I want
to like that was a good thing because
building God's work so why didn't he
just trusting God to take care of them
and if he does is a good thing then as
Christians today we go up sometime
to witness and to do the lot work so
should we carry SWAT to or some kind of
weapon to protect ourselves
no well there's two different things if
you're engaged in a war and this is
talking about Nehemiah they were gonna
be attacked by their and their neighbors
and their only recourse was self-defense
as a nation you know all of us cheer
when we think about David going to fight
against Goliath we're all glad that
David took a sling and then later he
took a lie of sword David didn't go into
battle and say I'm just gonna go you
know quote scripture to Goliath he he
went in he said you know I got a fight
with a giant I need a weapon he trusted
the Lord but he used a weapon now if
you're out doing mission work that's
where I think you pray and you say Lord
send angels to guard me because you
certainly want to wouldn't want to be
out doing God's work in that way that's
a little different than when Nehemiah
and the soldiers were building the wall
so if you're out doing Christian mission
work I think a lot of missionaries have
just trusted in the Lord there's a
really incredible book called through
the gates of splendor by Elizabeth
Elliot she talks about her husband that
was killed as a missionary because he
refused to use a weapon he had they were
in the jungle so he had a weapon because
you know there's jungle animals but he
refused to use the weapon to save
himself against the akka Indians and
later his wife ended up converting their
murderers the disciple said Lord you
know we've got two swords and he said oh
you don't get the point and Peter took
out the sword to defend Jesus and Jesus
said put up your sword he that lives by
the sword will die by the sword
so if you're out doing Christian mission
work you know you want to take you want
to be cautious he's not being reckless
and walking right into the mouth of the
lion but I don't think you want to be
involved in mission work if you got to
carry a 45 you got to go find somewhere
else you know if I remember that story
correctly that you just mentioned I
think the son of the missionary that was
killed he ended up baptizing the one who
killed his father yeah he came back
incredible story yeah next one of their
babies Donna listening from Maryland
Donna welcome to the program Oh
hi and your question how are you hi my
question I'm doing well thank you um I
need your help
my boyfriend and I may be the occasion
to upon from sex before marriage and at
this point he is a problem and I was
wondering that the can help me with
Scripture absolutely I mean yeah well
the whole idea of the Bible is pretty
clear that the marriage was consummated
by the right for a man and woman to be
intimate you've got the wedding of Jacob
where it wasn't until you know the end
of the marriage that he went into the
tangi and while he thought it was a
tenth of Rachel it was Leah but anyway
that that's when it was actually
consummated and there's a the book of
Hosea talks about this and Jesus said
that the only grounds for divorce is
fornication that's sex outside of
marriage with someone other than the
person you're committed to if you read
in acts 15 when the disciples went out
preaching to the Gentiles
they said you we need to tell them to
abstain from fornication fornication
meant sexual activity outside of the
marriage covenant and of course you know
one of the reasons for that is very
practical the the reason for a husband
and wife to be able to enjoy that is
they're gonna procreate in many cases
they're gonna have children until that
covenant is made and made the marriage
ceremony is the sealing of that covenant
men and women need to keep themselves
pure and I'm not at all surprised that
you know a lot of young men try and talk
their girlfriends into saying oh well
we're already committed in our hearts so
we're married in our hearts before God
and I've heard that so many times I
can't believe it
so it must be okay and then you know
what they break up before the wedding
and then the girl feels violated she's
why did I fall for that be true Donna
and you'll be thankful now we got a book
we can offer you on that called marriage
divorce and remarriage and it does give
scripture on the subject of
sex and faithfulness if you'd like to
receive the book we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and ask the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and the book is called marriage divorce
and remarriage because some practical
biblical principles related to that
subject will Bentley send it to anyone
and you know pastor Rossi just I just
want to say a word more because we don't
get this question often but it is such
an epidemic problem in our society that
the media makes X look like shaking
hands with someone you mean it used to
be you know just something that was very
sacred you know or right that was
restricted to the marriage but it's I
can understand why young people are
confused there's an ever-growing number
of young people just living together
without even getting married and they
figure that well I need to get to know
the person and their idea of getting
know the person is to get to know the
person physically or intimately and I
heard a pastor say one time if you want
to find out if you're compatible with
somebody that usually isn't because you
share a bedroom try sharing a checkbook
you'll find out really quick if you're
compatible it means the plumbing usually
works friends don't you don't have to
pre try the plumbing alright next call
that we have is Eddie listening from
Loma Linda Eddie welcome to the program
good evening pastor Doug evening quick
question from Joshua 724 ok I'm going
there right now what is your question
about that it says that Joshua and all
Israel took akin his sons and his
daughters and they stoned him and then
Deuteronomy 24:16 says father shall not
be put to death for their children nor
shall children be put to death for their
father correct you're wondering why in
the world would his family be executed
if he's the one that stole well you'll
read that when he finally confessed his
sin they went and they found he had
hidden it underneath the carpet in his
tent yeah the family yeah the family was
an accessory they knew and when Joshua
gave everybody the call and said look
someone's been stealing who is
family had an opportunity to confess and
they didn't they stood behind their
father they all maintain the covering up
until they were exposed it is a very
serious it's a very serious thing you
know it is true that children are not
responsible for the sins of the parents
but if if a parent brings them in on the
crime and they become accessories and
they're responsible and it doesn't say
how old his sons and daughters it
doesn't yeah they may have been adult
children hey thank you appreciate that
and you know there's another question I
often get and maybe I shouldn't be
putting in my own questions but the sons
of Saul were killed for the sin of their
father and and David had them hung and
it's probably because they were
accessories of Saul or encouraging Saul
to kill the Gibeonites anyway yeah
otherwise the children are innocent all
right we're gonna go to our next caller
and we've got dotty listening in
Sacramento dotty welcome to the program
hi how are you doing good thanks for
calling I'm nervous because I've never
done this before but I have a question
and I've been praying about it I don't
know why it's so important to me but
when I don't know some I'm not satisfied
until I have an answer okay I was told
someone believes that what does the
Bible say about the sinners when they
die because he believes that when Jesus
comes back you know and he takes his
people back that the sinners stay behind
but eventually they will go to heaven as
well because they will eventually
recognize that God is a savior and he
just believed that and I I say it will
show me in the Bible but he can't
pinpoint I mean he gives me scriptures
but it doesn't I've always read in the
Bible where they perish and so I'm a
little confused well let me let me give
you some verses I'm glad you called
they'll be nervous and let me give you a
few verses and pastor Ross might help me
with this the Bible tells us in the
second book of
Saloni ins and it says when the Lord
Jesus is revealed this is verse 7 when
the Lord Jesus is revealed from heaven
with his mighty angels in flaming fire
taking vengeance on those that know not
God who do not obey the gospel of our
Lord then you go to 2nd Peter chapter 3
and it says that day of the Lord will
come as a thief in the night and where's
the one professor Ross it says that
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming you second Thessalonians talking
about the the Antichrist I'll look that
one up but let me just add another one
before I forget
it's Revelation chapter 20 verse 13 to
me this seems pretty clear it says
anyone that was not found written in the
book of life was cast into the lake of
fire so we know the devil and his angels
were there but also those who are not
found written in the book of life well
the devil is not written in the book of
life but also the unbeliever those who
are in rebellion against God and
ultimately the Bible says they are
consumed in this lake of fire yeah so
and then the verse I was going to read
is in 2nd Peter chapter 3 where he says
the day of the Lord will come as a thief
in the night in which the heavens will
pass away with a great noise the
elements will melt with fervent heat
both the earth and the works that are in
it will be burned up when the Lord comes
and this is 1st Thessalonians chapter 4
it says the dead in Christ rise and so
we are caught up to meet them in the air
and then it tells us that the wicked are
destroyed by the brightness of his gun
yeah the verse you're referring to I in
2nd Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 8 it
says that when the Lord comes the Lord
will consume with the breath of his
mouth and will destroy with the
brightness of his coming
so it's referring to the wicked the
lawless one 2nd Thessalonians 2:8 as a
parable of the the wheat and the tares
regarde says he'll gather the wicked
together and cast him into a furnace of
fire so a person really and then you get
Matthew 25 he says depart from me you
cursed into everlasting fire prepared
for the devil and his angels and so the
Lord is really really clear in the Bible
that
the wicked go to the lake of fire now
some people under misunderstand what
that lake of fire is it it isn't burning
yet that's at the end of the world and
everyone is punished according to what
they deserve and they're consumed the
Bible says they're devoured they perish
they don't start burning for billions of
years as some have taught you know we do
have a book talking about the second
coming of Christ took us about what
happens to the righteous as well as the
wicked it's called anything but secret
I'll be happy to send this to you Dottie
or anyone that's listening willing to
learn more about the second coming of
Christ the number to call is 883 five
six seven four seven and again just ask
for the book we'll be happy to send it
to you it's called anything but secret I
think we have time for at least one more
caller let's go to California we've got
Kurt Kayne Korean I guess is probably
not pronouncing your name correctly but
welcome to the program thank you could
you explain please
Isaiah 65 17 to 25 20 17 to 20 all right
we'll do our best it's several verses
Isaiah 65 and he said start with verse
17 I created new heavens and a new earth
and the former will not be remembered or
come into mind but be glad and rejoice
forever and what I create for behold I
create Jerusalem a rejoicing and her
people of joy and I will rejoice in
Jerusalem and joy in my people and the
voice of weeping will no longer be heard
in her nor the voice of crying no more
shall an infant from there live but a
few days nor an old man who has not
fulfilled his days for the child will
die a hundred years old now that's the
verse where people often get hung up
what the child will die a hundred years
old that word actually there can be
translated the child shall cease a
hundred years old what that means is a
child does not even stop being a child
until a hundred because the previous
verses are talking about how everyone
lives forever but the sinner being a
hundred years old will be a curse in
other words even after a hundred years
sinners are still forever accursed and
then says they'll build houses and
inhabit them they're planting vineyards
and eating the fruit of them it's not
saying children die at 100 years old
it's same children don't even stop being
children they grow more slowly proof for
that would be found in the early
chapters of Genesis where it says that
some of the patriarchs didn't even get
married till there are over a hundred
they they matured more slowly and when
you live forever you don't have to just
be you know like a puppy for six weeks
and then you're a dog they grow more
slowly and their childhood lasts longer
anyway do we have we don't have time for
another we got 21 seconds hey friends I
got 19 seconds to tell you thank you for
keeping us on the air if you like Bible
answers live you want to keep us on the
air we sure would be thankful during
this Thanksgiving season if you just
click donate at our website amazing
facts dot o-r-g god willing we'll study
his word together next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who
was behind this great shift discover the
truth behind god's law and how it was
changed visit sabbath truth calm what if
you could know the future what would you
do what would you change to see the
future you must understand the past
Alexander the Great becomes King when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
a hundred and fifty years in advance
Cyrus had been named Rahm was violent
they were ruthless they were determined
the Gospel writers see his death as a
fulfillment of salvation this intriguing
documentary hosted by pastor Doug
Batchelor explores the most striking
Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com journey back through time to
the center of the universe discover how
a perfect angel transformed into satan
the arts villain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
immunity that moved to read
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life the cosmic conflict if
God is good if God is all-powerful if
God is love then what went wrong if
you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at www.ge.com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 back so our ji
[Music]